All right, you did it.
Final week, final lesson of this incredible year,
studying apologetics, preparing your students
to be one step closer, to be entirely confident,
to walk across the stage of graduation,
and to engage their culture with the truth of the gospel.
I can't express how excited I am
to hear the stories of our students
and what they've been able to experience,
and the stories of students who started off
with this skepticism in doubt
and have been brought along into committed followers of Christ,
proclaiming the gospel far beyond the walls
of your youth group.
So this is excited, I'm excited, I hope you're excited.
There's just a couple of quick things
that I wanna bring to your attention
and talk through as you kind of prepare.
I hope, first and foremost,
I hope you are preparing to celebrate.
This has been a, probably one of some of the most difficult
topics that some of your students
have ever dealt with in church studying,
and that's awesome, that makes me very, very excited.
So I'll take the time to celebrate.
But the second thing is,
is take some time to do an inventory.
Go back, when you first started talking,
go back to where your students were.
Have your students go back to where they were,
and invite them to think through,
like, what was I thinking back,
go back to their notes,
and what were you thinking in lesson 1.1
versus how you're thinking now?
When the concept of apologetics was introduced
and the questions that you had
way back in the beginning,
have those questions been answered now?
What further questions do you have?
Where do we go from here?
How do we continue to move on?
For your seniors.
Ask them if they feel like they're ready.
And if they're not,
maybe ask them what you can do to help them
further be ready for the next step,
the next step in their lives,
whether it be military, whether it be college,
whether it be gap year, whatever it is,
what is next for them?
The next thing is success and failures.
For your storyteller,
you want someone that can tell a great story
about sharing the truth.
But keep this in mind.
You don't necessarily want to have somebody
who successfully shared the gospel every time.
Students are gonna need to see
some examples of sort of falling flat on their face
because they're probably going to,
and that's okay, and maybe that's a good thing
because you learn a lot more generally
from failure than you do from successes.
So have somebody that can express both sides,
especially if you can find somebody that failed,
learn from their failure and move down to some success.
Keep in mind and remind your students time and again
that it's not us who does the saving.
It is God's job.
I have this analogy I've often given students
and they're all gonna be in different places
and God's gonna have all different kinds of roles.
Some water, some plant, but it's God who causes the growth.
And I often talk about the wide range of jobs
from excavation to tree shaking.
I have this pastor friend of mine
that I call him a tree shaker
because he's one of those guys that is just so eloquent
and so good at talking about the gospel
that I think he can just say bless you
and people come to faith in Jesus.
He's just so good.
God has just gifted him in amazing ways.
So I call him a tree shaker, right?
He just walks up to the tree that has been just,
you know, ripened by a bunch of work
from a bunch of other people
and he just gets up there and shakes that tree
and the fruit just falls.
And that may be the giftings of some of your students,
but that's not necessarily the gifting
of all of your students.
I typically call myself an excavator.
I'm the guy that just messes people up
and gets the land ready to be planted
and gets them all confused and thinking
and gets people ready to hear truth
and understand what truth is.
It could be all over the map.
So just remember to encourage your students
that wherever they are on that spectrum
to be faithful to the gifts and talents
that God has given them,
that they're gonna face some challenges.
They're gonna face questions
that they don't have answers to all the time.
They're gonna have to seek them out.
They're gonna have awesome success
and they're gonna get the thrill
of leading someone to know Christ.
And remember, we continue to pray for you.
We continue to work really hard here
back at the home office to provide you
with the best possible resources
for you to disciple your students.
Like I said, we would love to hear your stories.
We would love to hear how this study
has impacted you and impacted your students.
Share them on Facebook,
share them on Twitter and Instagram.
Give us an email, give us a phone call,
whatever it takes,
let us know how this study has impacted you
and impacted your students in your ministry.